استقبل وزير الخارجية المصري
سامح شكري وزير الخارجية السوري
غينيا الاستوائية بسبب انتشار
فيروس ماربورج فيهما. وفقا لما
مع دول اخرى مثل الصين وروسيا.
اوصت هيئة الصحة العامة السعودية
جديدة تواجه بها المد الغربي.
فهل تؤتي هذه العقيدة ثمارها على
فيصل المقداد بزيارة هي الاولى
من نوعها منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات
لتؤكد القاهرة السعي لعودة دمشق
لمحيطها العربي. عقيدة روسية
شخص بالاختناق جراء العاصفة
الترابية التي ضربت البلاد.
وقاية وطني المملكة بتجنب السفر
الى دولتين في افريقيا وهما
الا ان فتور العلاقات مؤخرا بين
البلدين جعل المملكة تفتح الملف
المحموم بشأن حرب تلوح في الافق
بين الولايات المتحدة والصين.
سعودية بهدف تطوير برنامج نووي.
حيث بحثت الرياض الامر في واشنطن
يا هذا. الاحداث مغطة كشفت صحيفة
نيويورك تايمز الامريكية عن مساع
وخمسين مليار دولار العام
الماضي. وهنا رئيس هيئة الاركان
الامريكي لتستخدمان العملتين
المحليتين في تعاملاتهما
الامريكية المشتركة الجنرال مارك
ميلي يحذر من تصاعد لهجة الخطاب
وقال ان الجميع بحاجة الى الهدوء
في هذا الامر. يا لا راحة بالك
تحاكي الهجوم الجوي على العدو
كجزء من مناورات عسكرية للنايتو
سادة. حملة صينية باتجاه
الامريكان. بالافعال لا بالاقوال
على الجناح الشرقي. في القاعدة
الجوية الرومانية في كونيستانتا
اخطر الفيروسات وتصل فيه نسبة
الوفيات من ستين الى ثمانين
بالمائة. اعلنت وزارة الصحة
العراقية اصابة اكثر من خمسمائة
ذكرت وكالة الانباء الرسمية واس.
هذا الفيروس شديد العدوى ومن
التجارية الثنائية. علما ان
التبادل بين البلدين وصل الى مئة
للاقتصاد الامريكي. نعم الصين مع
البرازيل تتخليان عن الدولار
ثلاثمائة وخمسين مسلحا وسط تقدم
القوات الروسية على كافة
تعبيرها. مع اعلان وزارة الدفاع
الروسية عن تصفية اكثر من
في الشرق الاوكراني لا يزال صعبا
للغاية في مناطق العمليات
يتخطى اصحاب العيون الضيقة
الحواجز. والعقبات تتدلل
الدفاعية. واضافت ماليار ان
القوات الروسية تهاجم من اربعة
برلمانيون من جلسة في البرلمان
النمساوي وذلك فور بدء خطاب
عليها مكان للحياد مكان للسلام.
كناية عن رفضهم لاوكرانيا في
قالت نائبة وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني انا ماليار ان الوضع
اوكرانيا ستكون صعبة للغاية.
وبالعودة الى الارض الاوكرانية.
ابيها. مشددة على ان بلادها
ستبقى دوما مع روسيا في خندق لقد
للصينيين مع كل خطوة فها هي بكين
وبخطوة اخرى توجه بها ضربة قوية
المحاور. في الاثناء كانت امريكا
ورومانيا تجريان تدريبات عسكرية
عن اي تدريبات يتحدثون وعن اي
محاكاة والمخازن الغربية تنضب يا
روسيا ستحرق الاسلحة التي تفاخر
بها واشنطن والغرب عن بكرة
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي عبر تقنية
الفيديو. تاركين خلفهم رسالة كتب
روسيا خلال العام الجاري. واضاف
ميلي ان خطوة كهذه من جانب
القوات الاوكرانية لن تكون قادرة
على استعادة الاراضي بالكامل من
الحرب العسكرية ضد روسيا. وجاءت
الصدمة القوية من رئيس هيئة
اتجاهات في وقت واحد وهي ليمان
وباخموت ومالينكا وافدي افكا وفق
كثرت تلميحاتك تجاه الشاب
بوتينيا كيميوك لنعتبره غزلا
الاركان الامريكية المشتركة
الجنرال مارك ميلي الذي قال ان
نوويا. والصفعات تتوالى على
خدنسكي وهذه المرة انسحب
الامريكية يمكن ان تحمي بلاده من
روسيا. وكانت يوقد قالت سابقا ان
اراضيها ستبقى محتلة وهذا غير
مقبول على الاطلاق بما رد الكريم
من ان هذا طرح خطير للغاية.
بعينيها الضيقتين. ها هي كيميو
متعددة المهام من طراز الرسومات
بتمويل من الاتحاد الاوروبي
هنا تعود واشنطن مجددا معلنة
تقديم حزمة مساعدات جديدة لكييف
من اربعمائة يوم. وفي كل يوم
يزداد لهيبها على جميع المجالات.
والولايات متحدة. بولندا لا
تمانع ولكن هل تمول اوروبا
وواشنطن هذه العملية? ليتجه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لدراسة ومناقشة
شقيقة الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
تدخل خط الحرب الاوكرانية محذرة
نشر قوات حفظ سلام اوروبية في
اوكرانيا. لكن اوكرانيا تقول ان
الجيش الامريكي بحسب البنتاجون.
مما جعلهم يسعون لانتاج خمسة
هذه الحزمة قد تساعد اوكرانيا في
هجوم الربيع المضاد ياتي الرد
بينما وجهت اوكرانيا ايديها نحو
بولندا طالبة منها مائة مدرعة
فورا من الكرملين على هذا
التصعيد الامريكي. وذلك باعلان
الاسلحة العادية وعالية الدقة
استعدادا لحرب طويلة الامد.
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو
عن زيادة انتاج جميع انواع
تتضمن دخائر جوية دقيقة بقيمة
مليارين وستمائة مليون دولار.
ولكن خسائرها تثقل الغربيين. هذه
الحرب الاوكرانية مر عليها اكثر
الرئيس الاوكراني بانه مخطئ
باعتقاده ان المظلة النووية
الحرب المعقدة طرفاها روسيا
واوكرانيا ومن خلف ستار امريكا
لوكاشينكو مقدما اقتراحه للغرب.
فاما التصعيد او هدنة في الحرب
وسبعين الف طلقة شهريا بحلول عام
الفين وخمسة وعشرين. يا لهذه
في اوكرانيا دون حق تغيير مواقع
القوات او نقل المعدات والاسلحة
من الاسلحة بما يتعدى الالتزامات
المعلنة مقرا بان برلين لن
العالم من روسيا منذ غزوها
الشامل وفق اهذا كل ما استطعتم
هل يترك الامريكان مشاكلهم
ليهتموا بك خليك في حالك عام لكن
الرصاص والقنابل وذلك لان الحرب
في اوكرانيا الحقت اضرارا بمخزون
ثالثة بحرائق نووية. مؤكدا ان
روسيا دولة وستستخدم اكثر
يبدو ان واشنطن منهمكة بحل
مشاكلها اولا. فهنا يعلن
نفوس الغربيين والبداية من
المانيا. حيث اعلن وزير دفاعها
البنتاجون انه يتجه لزيادة تاجه
من الذخائر التقليدية وخاصة
تستطيع سد ثغرات الدفاعية التي
احدثتها عمليات تسليح كييف بحلول
تهتم بالناتو وباوروبا فاننا
سنواجه تحديات كبيرة وخطيرة. لكن
اعلنتها روسيا هي احدث مثال على
التصعيد الخطابي الذي يشهده
عقيدة تتحدث يا بوتين لترد
الخارجية الامريكية. لكن بعد
ساعات من الصمت ان العقيدة
الدبلوماسية الجديدة التي
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يوقع
مرسوما ليعتمد نسخة جديدة لعقيدة
بوريس بيستوريوس ان بلاده لم تعد
قادرة على تسليم اوكرانيا مزيدا
الفين وثلاثين. ليستنجد بوريس
بالرئيس الامريكي قائلا ان لم
ان بوتين يرجح ان احتمال
الانتقال الى حرب كبرى يزداد
الاسلحة رعبا اذا ما هدد الوضع
بانهيارها. هناك دب الخوف في
وواشنطن ترد بمحاكاة نووية.
شقيقة مجنون كوريا الشمالية تدخل
الجديدة. فغارات تكشف واخرى تغلق
في المواجهة الروسية الغربية.
ومرعب. والمياه تعود لمجاريها
بين مصر وسوريا. عقيدة بوتين
بما في ذلك النووية وحذر
لوكاشينكو من اندلاع حرب عالمية
لا اكون. اسلحة ودعم امريكي جديد
بمليارين ونصف المليار دولار
مخاطر صدام المتنامي بين الدول
الكبرى خصوصا الدول النووية. حتى
قوله يا ابناء العم سام ليتدخل
الرئيس البلاروسي الكسندر
ما مر. البرلمان النمساوي للرئيس
الاوكراني لا مكان لك هنا. روسيا
والهند لمواجهة ما يسميه الهيمنة
الامريكية في العالم. فعن اي
ليركز في عقيدته المستحدثة على
تعميق التعاون بين روسيا والصين
تتجه نحو اوكرانيا ورئيس هيئة
الاركان الامريكية يصدم الجيش
نادي الدول النووية والصحة
السعودية تحذر من فيروس جديد
الاوكراني بنتيجة الحرب.
والبرازيل تنضم الى بكين لتوجيه
ضربات متبادلة بين الشرق والغرب.
يتجه الى المجهول. ها هو الرئيس
السياسة الخارجية لبلاده. اطلق
علي الحرب الهجينة وذلك لمواجهة
نحن نعتذر لا اسلحة لاوكرانيا
بعد اليوم. هكذا اعلنتها
خط الحرب الاوكرانية. فيما رئيس
بيلاروسيا يضع اوروبا بين خيارين
ضربة للولايات المتحدة العراقيون
يختنقون. والرياض تطرق ابواب
المانيا. بينما روسيا تضاعف
مخازن اسلحتها. بل كشفت الحرب
تبدأ الهجوم على اربعة محاور
اوكرانية. والهدف منها اكون او
المدى القريب?
عورات الغرب الدفاعية وبوتين
يعلن عن عقيدة عسكرية جديدة